donc pour les troubles menstruels
donc en fait vous avez compris que nous
le réseau on est surtout là pour
identifier finalement les signaux enfin
les signaux les potentiels signaux et
ensuite c'est à charge de l' agence
finalement de faire tout l'aspect
réglementaire remonte et échanges avec
le m nous on est là pour s'assurer que
tout ce qui se passe avec les vaccins et
la vaccination en termes d'effets
indésirables nous soit remontée alors
vous avez les moyens il ya le portail
bref en ce qui concerne les troubles
menstruels
troubles menstruels la vaccination pour
les femmes en âge de procréer 1 qui
peuvent être conseillés concerné par les
troubles mensuel elle débute à partir
d'avril 2021 et dès le mois de juin on
repère effectivement qu'il ya des
saignements et des saignements mensuel
qui nous surprennent et donc on indique
effectivement au comité de suivi en juin
2021 que ces troubles la
nous préoccupe je sais pas si ça nous
préoccupe en tout cas nous surprennent
et qu'on souhaite les suivre
particulièrement on en fait un deuxième
suivie en juin en juillet au comité de
suivi suivant on en refait en septembre
et là en septembre on a travaillé donc
les deux vaccins arn mais également les
vaccins à des no parce qu'on est
effectivement surpris du nombre de
déclarations sur ce sujet là on comprend
pas très bien comment ça fonctionne
parce que les tableaux sont très larges
ça va du saignement à l'aménorrhée
c'est-à-dire à l'absence de règles à des
douleurs utérine très très violente et
donc on décide d'en faire un descriptif
très précis donc on a pris en septembre
la totalité des observations qu'on avait
reçu pour pouvoir les analyser très
précisément un parent catskill cas qui
ont été regardés dans le blanc des yeux
un par un et on a donc
proposé un rapport en décembre décrivant
très précisément les caractéristiques
des des événements qui nous étaient
rapportés alors nous au niveau français
depuis le mois de juin on considère que
ces cas là sont à suivre parce que à
titre individuel on est là on entend ce
que nous disent ces femmes qui disent
qu'elles sont réglés régulièrement et
qu'elles sont déréglés ou qu'elles ont
des saignements plus abondants mais on
n'a pas
au titre collectif on n'a pas les moyens
nous de faire les estimations collective
donc l'estimation collective elle
revient à l'europe l'europe elle a été
saisie de cette question cet été l'été
2021 et en décembre 2021 décide de clore
le sujet parce qu'il estime qu'il est
compliqué de trancher parce que comme
les troubles menstruels c'est quelque
chose d'assez fréquent en population
générale est que c'est multifactoriel
notamment avec les les histoires de
stress en fait le le le
l'europe des sites que finalement elle
n'a pas les moyen d'estimer si jamais il
ya un lien avec le vaccin est clos le
signal d'un professeur quand vous dites
l'europe il s'agit de qui que
l'institution exact alors l'europe c'est
l'institution voilà je laisserais madame
ratinier compléter mes donc le rock
c'est le la commission de
pharmacovigilance européenne qui se
réunit tous les mois et qui discutent
tous les signaux au niveau européen qui
décide après avoir expertiser le signal
que le signal hill le clos alors quand
il veut quand il veut le faire mais ça
veut pas dire qu'ils arrêtent de le
suivre
ça veut juste dire qu'ils ont apporté
une première réponse qui est une réponse
de on n'a pas trouvé de signal ou en
tout cas on pense pas qu'il y ait de
lien donc si je si je comprends bien
au début c'est vous qui
avait identifié un signal simplement par
des témoignages recueillis exactement a
décidé alors de sepa d'été des
déclarations ce sont des déclarations de
serma covigilance déclaration de farouk
audiences s'étaient pas quelque chose
qui était a priori attendu donc ça vous
dit pas du tout et donc il était tout à
fait logique 2-0 liens
de s'en préoccuper de faire un lien et
puis ensuite donc quand vous faites le
signalement et que la question se pose
au niveau de l'institution de la
commission sur mac os vision européenne
qui elle pour mission d'évaluer les
choses de façon collective au niveau
européen décide de clore l'instruction
pour absence de absence de preuves a en
tout cas pour l'absence d'éléments qui
leur fait penser qu'il peut y avoir un
lien avec la vaccination est en fait à
la suite du travail qui a été fait alors
nous très précisément au niveau français
mais aussi d'études notamment aux états
unis très précises l'europe a décidé de
rouvrir le signal en septembre en
février je suis arrivé en février 2000
22 sur deux points particuliers donc le
point des saignements abondants qui gêne
la vie quotidienne et le point d
aménorrhée donc d absence de règles
pendant plus de trois mois
donc ça c'est cette enquête est en cours
et on attend les résultats de l'enquêté
au niveau européen pour le mois de juin
de cette année donc le signal en fait
bien sûr a été réouvert devant le nombre
de cas et les nombreux pays on n'était
pas les seuls les norvégiens les suédois
les anglais ont insisté en disant il ya
quand même beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
volume alors se sont souvent
effectivement des effets qui sont
considérés comme non graves parce qu ils
n'amènent pas à l'hospitalisation ça
dure un cycle donc c'est pas considéré
comme grave mais c'est considérer
suffisamment impactant la vie des gens
qui sont concernés pour que ça fasse
l'objet d'une préoccupation
[Musique]